Gregory is Alba here Jabby coag's other
coolidge a boa jab eco I say it three
times in the mirror they'll come out and
kill you huh hi there my name is Greg
Alba so a couple weeks ago it was my
brother's birthday his name is javi
Kovac you should go check out his
youtube channel it's struggling right
now barely any subscribers of view
account incredibly low god I feel sorry
for the guy anyway
he recently turned 47 years old good for
him
he looks great for his age and on the
day of his birthday his presents really
late on the day of his birthday I
actually had an idea of what to get him
little did I know it would take me a lot
longer to put together than I realized
basically I have taken a snippet out of
every single video he has been on for
the real rejects and made a little
compilation out of it I chose the
moments based off of what I thought was
awkwardly funny or minorly funny this
probably could have been a lot shorter
but [ __ ] we're here anyway it made me
laugh so maybe it might make you kind of
smile I'm really happy to be here for
him I love the guy he's helped me out a
lot
I'm excited to see the comments come in
people haven't been around that long who
are like why is Greg calling himself
Ryan right well there's a whole story to
that but it makes it pretty apparent in
the video that the kind of humor I used
to rely on is Ryan Reich would not fly
by in these times at YouTube this video
definitely has a yellow dollar bill sign
because of comments I make anyway I love
you jab Yuka way congratulations on
storing 58 enjoy the video I'm nervous
they say in public speech you know
sometimes it's good to just say you're
nervous and makes you connect with the
crowd right away I said you've done I
hate when people say they're nervous why
oh I took speech class and people would
say sorry I'm nervous right now I'm like
just shut up and do your speech stop
saying you're nervous
sometimes you got to get it off your
chest first in order to just do a great
though I'm never nervous at anything
ladies that's not true it's not sure
I've had some horrible incidents do you
have a lighter shirt because this is I
look like angelically bright no you look
great okay
you look great it symbolizes you hey
guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jesus apparently
Jesus is my brother and my Lord and
Savior
hi Flyers tag team can I get a shout out
friend may bra kid perv dude what is
high flyers tag team exactly I mean are
you guys like tag team in like low
flyers like you guys are like just
taking care of one little flyer at a
time double stuff you know what I mean
huh I don't think they worry about the
low flyers I think they're all up here
and they'll all right you're taking over
I don't know I don't know what that
means making it double penetration Jeff
original gamer you give me a shout-out
please original gamer you are the first
one to ever play a game and I am proud
of you for doing that thank you for
being the first he is like 97 years old
original gamer it was one man by himself
in the 1910s
I don't know pretty no games had ever
existed everyone thought he was crazy
little did they know he was on the cusp
of a revolution what are doing
we're just saying I think you're taking
over my channel brother I got a question
what why are most of these subscribers
like a literal lineman a lot of them
just don't know how to type a literal
illiterate a literal the literals the
word is it a word is Navy that's not a
word illiterate and now the word you're
the role I'm try to make a point here
that there a literal sea is bad don't
make me look dumb
it's the syntax that you're talking
about let's see what you look like buddy
okay okay Wow Wow okay you have a photo
here can't show it because there's a
girl in the photo but you have your
tongue out and you have a crucifix
around your neck I'm telling you right
now if you have a crucifix around your
neck this is a major sin what you are
doing with this girl you are suggesting
oral fellatio with this woman by
sticking your tongue
she looks like she is down for it is
that a good representation of being a
Catholic my friend I think he just wants
a little teapot you want something to
pop you know what I mean and in this
photo you look like a straight-up serial
killer you're not gonna show these to
the audience I'll show the serial killer
one there you guys go there's been an
awakening
[Music]
ah [ __ ] you Instagram you and your
15-second video it's like Skywalker
that's awesome guy Walker that's so cool
you know people are gonna think we're
race is just for pointing out the fact
that he's black I'm cheering it on that
I'm sure on I see more blacks in Star
Wars yes please all black Star Wars cast
for a spinoff Family Matters meets Star
Wars social networks yet Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine periscope so
follow us there
jab eco a real rejects you know how it
is dogs because if we get enough
followers we can get even more product
placement you know what I said if I can
get enough if I can get enough going
with YouTube and short films and whatnot
I'm gonna amass money from Kickstarter
to do a fan film Oh Star Wars versus
Star Trek like a legit one that's pretty
cool but you interrupted my segue into
the product placement like dude what's
the product placement well now I lost my
train of thought
I usually pick up a prop what's your
price place again I could be like Oh
green tea green tea is gray the kinds
uses black tea black tea is great you
know the another thing that's also great
that come from the blacks is their huge
huge testicles they got big testicles
and small penises that's how the cliche
goes yeah fill it in this bottle when
you drink it black tea more like black
pee that is what really provides you in
nutrients it'll make you pee this really
isn't a product placement from like team
this is more like black people's urine
I'm promoting I don't know where this is
going I'm just this is what happens
interrupt me yeah be here
my broseph Joseph from the same moseph
here we go we're gonna check out the
trailer for kill your friends the
biographical story of javi koi you can
check out jab Iike way on the jab eco a
channel as Evan is or go to youtube page
comm YouTube page calm
that URL you know YouTube page calm you
really bought that your guys go click on
it right now YouTube page calm does it
have to be YouTube page or can it be
like like fresh vegetables calm what I
think we have a fan base that is really
like vegetable drawn or like minor meat
eaters or medium sized penises calm I
tried to get [ __ ] arts calm I have
been defending Tom Cruise the way I've
been defending Mel Gibson through this
crisis lately watching the clips of him
and collateral in like that's the movie
where he's playing an antagonist he was
a superstar already at that time right
and he was totally believable as his bad
guy right I remember that first time
like he pulls out a gun and kills people
when Jamie Foxx's handcuffed to the car
actually down here I thought was
handcuffed to the UM whatever Oh
steering wheel whatever it is he's
handcuffed right and he goes to get his
suitcase back and he takes up those two
guys like babes like screw shots to the
chest and one to the head it was so
quick I'd never seen anything like that
before he whips out that gun really fast
yeow-kee imagine him in bed that's what
that thing out you be more gas me before
even you Javier Bardem yeah totally
totally belongeth he's kind of got
typecast as villains ever since then
granted I've only seen him play one
other villain so I don't know if he's
been typecast no he played a lover who
got two women into bed at the same time
in a Woody Allen movie that is kind of
villainous because of you know that
emotionally confusing for that [ __ ] was
so slick I'm like I need to try that out
one day when I'm actually single I've
tried everything from movies and we're
gonna check out the official teaser
trailer for the highly anticipated Oscar
contender wordy
what's another smart work brilliant
brilliant film Angry Birds you know what
I'm don't say that I'm pleasantly
surprised by this trailer that looks so
adorable and I like seeing a it's a I
like seeing the concept they took a bit
of taking this main bird and it has
anger problems to try to deal with it I
would have liked to see I would want to
have seen some kind of
dr. Seuss asked analogy for the war on
terror or something like that
I don't know taking some kind of adult
theme but simplifying it a digital to
some kind of children understanding
children level there was a dr. Seuss
book like that about nuclear war it was
about the egg
that could like blow up everything that
would be cool
there's no angry sorry this sailor isn't
the plot you were looking for but as far
as the plot that about what was that
about it's like it looks like a
DreamWorks Animation kind of movie or a
fun Pixar kind of film it's a comedy and
this character has anger issues and
stuff man does see it didn't seem like
it whatsoever he talked about the
enemies of welcoming Angry Birds who's
trying to control his anger and then he
got hit the Tri control his anger more
than he just blew up and these are about
birds with anger problems it sounds so
funny to me well we've grown up with
people with anger issues and you know
what that looks like it's closer to you
I don't want to watch a realistic kids
movie have an anger no it could be funny
still it can be funny but it's just I
didn't see him like actually explode the
way I expect you just from playing the
little iPad game I feel like you're
being a little over analytical here when
it comes to this ink I'm not being
hypercritical whatsoever it's an angle
it's based off of video game app it's
okay that it even has a little bit of a
story
I can't watch inside out ever again
seriously there's a and then you'll
reflect too hard that sounds like it's
your defense mechanisms against Angry
Birds I'm gonna go cry now
we don't have to be a [ __ ] about it I'm
kidding cranes good I've cried five
times on this channel what's kalibo see
you again that paul walker song yeah
ryan right yeah my Stallone has Down
syndrome that's how I do my
impressionist alone hello I'm javi
kawaii
Luther no no that's how you doing dude -
I don't think rocky 4 is the best rocky
it's actually one of the worst ones
it wouldn't surprise me if you thought
that was the best it's not the bests I
thought Rocky 5 was the best
growing up I thought it was the best -
with all the hip-hop music and then I
got older and realized this is the worst
one of the moment I sighed two days ago
I've been watching all them again yeah
but you're not watching it in context
like you got at the time that the movie
came out it made sense because we were
afraid of the Cold War and robots
I thought the rocky franchise lost all
sense of reality when rocky fought Hulk
Hogan in part three they have a
wrestling match that was that was a
charity organization yeah but he is like
[ __ ] the hell out of rocky and rocky
just keeps getting back up as if like
there's no injury the Italian stallion
oh you cannot defend that there's no
sense of reality after that [ __ ]
paulie getting the robot mm-hmm what
that was realistic he was he's a wealthy
guy no seriously he's a wealthy guy he
could have anything in the world
paulie's I mean paulie's Paul he's a
weird guy wait what did Molly did Paulie
give him the robot or no no rocky gave
Paulie the robot that makes perfect
sense what where did you get the robot
it was a gift I mean it was they sell
those robots in the 80s they had mr. the
mr. robot toy for Nintendo that's just
an extension of that we were obsessed
with robots Robocop the Rockies and I
five pictures I have the guy who looks
like wall-e
the big one I think you're just trying
to piss me off right now rocking forward
awful I know something the Rocky movies
there's always someone who has to tell
Rocky
you can't do it and it was Adrian in
that he takes off in the car montage of
all the other rocky films
the only memories rocky hazzle Apollo
are footage from the last three Rocky
films II have no friendship outside
getting him shot like some extra footage
for the movie right which Rocky was it
where he was showering at the beginning
and he was all messed up from the last
fight live that was Rocky five five
takes place like immediately after the
boxing match at four that was the only
good scene in that movie was the opening
you know how that makes you sound what
you just said the only good scene is
when Rocky is showering at the opening
you know all right
not because he's showering not because
he's naked but because you've seen he's
vulnerable the fron with the Rocky
movies is that it came so villain heavy
with three and four and five - you
didn't enjoy that running scene on the
beach with Creed when they're in the
shorts I did that was hilarious because
they're first they're running and
there's been their zooming down their
quads I was like all right a little gay
whatever but then once they jump in the
water and start hugging each other I'm
like they went all out with this whole
new level that was acceptable in the 80s
and it wasn't gay yeah now it's awkward
my gays more acceptable is that weird
that is interesting
it's like now we have more percent we
have we perceive more things as as gay
ish but we're more accepting of the gap
the gays this Creed's manager I don't
remember the black guy who's always like
don't do it like every every Rocky movie
he's crying in the corner it's emotional
it's very emotional follow us on social
networks because because you should you
should root internet personalities if
you'd like us here you will like us more
on the other social media because of the
image we portray exactly my you'll get
more of this through words exactly and
photos just make up your entire identity
off Instagram photos and Twitter posts I
have a photo of a banana well that's
pretty accurate yo you like bananas
exactly and I've got really funny tweets
and so do you don't have funny tweets no
but I tweet out these funny videos yes
you can follow us on our social networks
because if we get enough followers we
can get more product placement because
money is the root of all happiness yes
the whole jelly bean thing I how do you
feel about that in the in the movie the
jelly bean moment or the Jolly Rancher
moment the Jolly Rancher moment was
probably most powerful moment in the
whole movie being serious or new it
really showed the evil seductive side of
Lex Luthor well I can't tell you answer
cuz it was like he's going to do this
with a man you know it wasn't like it's
kind of like when Javier Bardem was you
know touching James Bond's legs and
Skyfall mm you know no
some uncomfortable moment yeah just like
that moment sac Snider knew exactly what
he was doing it'll kind of stuck on the
bullets the the kryptonite bullets yeah
Batman no is how powerful Superman is
why was he shooting at him with anything
other than kryptonite ever actually
didn't ever think of that I don't know
why I can't tell if you know I'm being
serious
oh okay I can never tell and I don't
know I don't know why this is the first
time I'm hearing this I feel like well
yeah it's so obvious a lot of people
should have told me before
because I can't tell with you I can't
sell I feel like you're really good at
[ __ ] with me boy they're being
serious now I'm totally serious okay but
I never heard that before
Wow this movie just gets stupid to all
the woman out there who watch this
channel I'm single
who beat you to the punch is that what
you were gonna say okay he wasn't gonna
say I was gonna say it stick to for them
to stop contacting me so much Oh cuz I'm
getting bombarded these days with
constant female fans all the time
messaging me yeah leave him alone and
come over to Jimmy's channel I'll
welcome you
I'm not supposed to hear what you just
said because I heard everything you just
said don't be so coy I have an idea for
a lethal weapon five that I'm gonna talk
about soon no that's a great idea it's
seriously a good idea that we're gonna
happen yeah I know but if they did it I
would know how to do it okay okay cool
it's really good
great tuck that in with your dream for a
four-way
I love Body of Lies I love Body of Lies
if you haven't seen Body of Lies it's a
great [ __ ] movie I loved about it was
it's really good you didn't see it like
I saw you didn't like it no oh I thought
it was awesome
come on I'm gonna say thank you to all
you subscribers for being so kind to me
these days I love you and you love me
too
and that love can never be broken
unless you want social Donnie Yen I hear
is a blind guy and I you know what I
realized
I think the blind community is
eventually gonna take a stand we've got
two characters in daredevil who are
blind
you got this movie coming out called
don't breathe about a blind guy and then
you got this movie coming out with a
blind warrior but the prom they don't
cast any real blind actors to play these
characters well sure the blind community
is like me he's very upset when they
watch these I have you know as someone
who's actually but how much more then
the trailer showed us do you think
Donnie Yen will actually be fighting 15
minutes I think it's the one fight scene
they gave him I think this fight scene
won't be maybe a minute or two long
before the force is gonna play a role in
all of this just not quite as heavy I
always feel like the force was the worst
part of the Star Wars movies I want you
all to know that the worst part okay is
the one thing that doesn't work for me
all right that's a good joke it's a joke
I love Hayden Christensen is Anakin
Skywalker bring him back Jar Jar Binks
he was pretty funny
jab eco a yes is an adopted family
member of mine that's why he has a
different name his parents were killed
there were two lights in there yellow
and red still to this day he doesn't
know who did
don't represent what ya shown
referencing I want to give a shout out
to my sister it was her birthday
yesterday
happy birthday McGann that's the correct
way to pronounce her name she's an
artist she has curly hair and she gets
irritated easily and I love you the rest
of our bloodline I don't like that he's
rock climbing while he's shooting I
personally disagree without rock
climbing while he's shooting he's not
shooting anything right now but he's
still because he might shoot something
later Yeah right
I completely disagree you're really
upset over the fact of his personal life
choice to go rock life yeah because
that's just risky yo I am a balance I'm
a happy medium yo like him him doing
this it's just like Harrison Ford flying
that plane and crashing it when we all
thought that Harrison Ford was gonna be
an episode date I just think that's
stupid to take chances with your life
you need 7 be new errors and photos in
episode 7 we didn't know he was dying in
episode 7 we thought he might be an
episode 8 still so him taking chances
with his life was just obnoxious that's
why I find this to be obnoxious like
don't take chances with your life when
there's a possibility you might still be
in this movie you're gonna [ __ ] up so
much money there and make the it studios
to go find someone to replace why does
it want ever I was just kidding you know
one of those automated rock climbing
things you can climb in his backyard
it's the same thing huh that's way
better it's safer he'll fall on grass
instead of a thousand is about the
experience of doing that give him VR
goggles give him oculus rifts that he
can feel like he's climbing [ __ ] not the
same thing it's about reality have you
seen someone like feel like they're
falling when they're using the oculus
rift they scream their heads off cuz
they think they're actually falling it
controls your senses yeah but I think in
real life either you're smart
additionally on Facebook the other day
there Hawk ulis rift is helping people
to learn how to walk again people who
were formerly paralyzed or now we're
getting feeling in their feet because
their brain is learning what it's like
to walk again
oculus rift is the real [ __ ] yo he could
just do off those rip instead of taking
chances with his life like that that's
all I'm saying
you can disagree with me I don't give
you [ __ ] I just think it's dumb don't
take chances with your life that's it
subscribe to Gregory's channel subscribe
to Jabby Kawai I still like your dare
hey hey Anthony I mean he lives right
next door to me now so I invited him
over to come do this unite the league
trailers one for Batman and one for
Aquaman I'm just giving you guys a heads
up I might be a little late to doing the
official trailer because I have an event
to go to on Saturday strip club it's
important that's important and mess that
up and Justice League will have to wait
and no one really cares about cyborg but
he's in it anyway he looks like Trevor
Noah it's not just cuz he's black
alright another section ever Noah and I
could be Aquaman for Halloween yeah he's
gotta do some push-ups
oh I guess you could yeah I mean sure
alright well you can subscribe to the
real rejects hey click that notification
bell got a little note here to do that
jab eco ways on the jab eco a channel go
to Jabby tube if you want to see videos
great reactions and movie reviews and
whatnot I've got the American channel
and the international channel the
internationals like Bollywood Korean
cinema Japanese cinemas international
one's huge and blowing up it gets way
more views than a lot of us out there
damn foreigners Jabby tube youtube.com
slash - Jimmy - Jimmy - Jimmy - it's not
a porn site it's not a porn site and
that's the most important piece of
information you'll get all day people
yes I have to go do things now good bye
hi I'm Greg I'm Jenny Kawai I'm a
psychic hey you guys have seen Game of
Thrones right yes if either Jon Snow or
Daenerys
were to gain power I think they'd both
be really good monarchs for the southern
king
and at the last second Tyrion takes over
yeah okay yeah that's a lot of wine and
everyone drops dead except for them my
favorite thing about Game of Thrones is
whenever someone calls jon snow a
bastard child yeah they all say at the
same busted child busted son of Ned
store they they can be having the most
casual conversation oh he's Jon Snow
he's a busted Sunday always a bust okay
it's like a curse it sucks to be a
bachelor there's so many bastards in
this world everyone's having sex with
horizontally yeah there's a lot of
bastards keep in mind that every time
you're doing a British accent
you're doing it next to someone who's a
British latest sweep yo Jimmy all weird
all will die hello reject nation Greg
Alba here
Jenica way Charlotte Kirk and Jabbok
away from the jab Eko a channel here
today to help me get nerdy cated here
that's a nerd and educated combined this
is the dead he got this in Japan when he
was like I remember this was like part
of the kitchen it doesn't bother Ted
these are his - it was glass oh thank
god more items that I could really use
in my life right now to find space for
them because my brother doesn't want to
hold on to these no no I have a bunch of
his stuff I just thought that you should
have some of it also what's this it's
some dead collected random things that
was one of them I had them separately
might display case and I was like Oh
Greg should have some of this because he
doesn't have anything related to death
well thank you yes yeah picot it oh
sweet lightning man that's why so you
can tell me what this stuff is I'm a big
fan of the flash TV show I don't read
the comics but this is cool I gotta
learn how to so you know so every Asian
woman knows that is yeah my aunt used to
do not racist at all well I want to put
this on a pair of jeans I can write on
my crotch woman ASAP and she will stitch
it to your chest for you oh it's an
iron-on pad that's what you mean I can
just iron it on yeah not like Iron Man
yeah Gregory just needs to find an iron
oh it's true and an iron board and then
I'm halfway there people well you could
just use your leg and iron that's you
know that's how you do it like a male oh
that's so cool this is the words that
would go off when Gabby would beat me up
when I was young I have no idea how to
do that grab a PNG of it and drop it on
top like a picture work this could be
hurting someone noises or sex noises
whichever one you want them to be I look
like hope to be Church noises bang said
a prayer no shirt oh my god I want it
wait can I have this one please oh this
is no that's the one thing I always use
from these guys I wonder this is too big
for you so we should wealth wear it at
the same time we could both fit into it
at the same time which would be a very
comfortable brother experience it could
be like a creature out of never ending
story like I'll be on one side you'll be
on the other foot back to back
I claim logos so you gotta be on the
black side all right once you go black
you never go back
that's true that's true I've had many
black men in my life ever since hi guys
it's Greg here is javi editorial this is
shara we're gonna unbox something Warner
Brothers sent over some awesome crap to
me pretty sure they can cue you off the
show know you always got a shout and
lower it in iMovie
this fat-ass pockets at me alright oh my
god I want this burger wait wait don't
start grabbing stuff make it special
oh my god Barbie doll looks like a bee
could you take pictures there are so
many nice things I wish I didn't tell
people I was getting this box because
there's like more than three people now
who won at least one item for me from
his box
I have so many things I would do with
that that's hashtag not per beat we
gotta get my shirt I just watch the
video the video you said you giveaway go
pro cameras I was pissed
yeah well you know what that's what you
do when you're desperate for gifts for
people that you really do you have
GoPros no I know that
oh yeah all right Jackie which one do
you want okay whatever you want
oh sorry guess what okay there you go it
started that's so nice I want this bag
how am I giving the girl the sword
no no different these give her those no
that's a collectible you keep forever
Greg wants them give away though
actually I would keep that and give her
this one I think it's rose right but you
can wear these in other videos after
your review you can use these mom man
you're gonna keep this one we're giving
the girl this onesie in the crappy yes
yeah but you deserve a good gift all
right you can have the bag Greg's new
something like toy American sausage
holder we'll get this one
what hey she refers to be called penis
hole I'm just excited that they're all
back I can't wait for these child actors
to grow up and be miserable adults from
having a successful child acting see
you're right when they pop it what's
going on reject nation it's Greg Alba
here jelly Kawai what's up shabby Kawai
my brother from the same sister is right
here
next to me do you not like horror I
wouldn't say I'm like a huge horror fan
but I'll watch it as a horror fan myself
I think this looks pretty cool actually
then I think did I just go to some
downvotes cuz I said I'd talk much more
regularly no no no no no we get down
boats no matter what we do so I got in
one end of the spectrum you have
Slenderman
starting from the internet the other end
is [ __ ] my dad says okay well is that
basically the scene with a checkout
jabby TV on the youtubes yes he has a
really thriving international channel
through so good right now I'm so happy
for him yeah but he has an American
channel that he just relaunched and you
guys should check it out a lot of great
videos that the real rejects is crushing
by the way but yeah my heir to patreon
page we have has become like a second
youtube channel I saw that we got like
six new pledges today so that's really
growing right now one of those may you
reap I did and then pledged again oh
well that looks good on the
notifications have you ever played truth
or dare and a half-hearted way I managed
to get a few make-out sessions that way
it was pretty awesome Wow a dream that I
never lived alright guys well what do
you think of happy deathday or Ouija
origin of evil the final destination or
the ring would you rather
[Music]
click the notification bell borrowing
you fall javi TV so on YouTube
checking our patreon become a patron
ejected a it's like a second youtube
channel any more questions
it's do you really think it's that
derivative of this videos done three I
would agree with this one it was just a
reboot basically with a new kid yeah
it's not continuing the same villains or
the same Cavin looks like my coldly :
it's cute it looks like Macaulay Culkin
and we'll double down on the amount of
villains 90s and stuff where it's like
yeah yeah yeah it's that premise you
know
did you guys see home alone three I did
I really wish they would create a home
alone cinematic universe where all the
kids eventually come together to take
down all the back home invasion
apparently multiple kids who could take
on multiple bad guys breaking into the
room make it the raid bad guys the
heroes actually the robbers the kids
yeah it's gone too far now these kids
are all missed this is an obvious thing
I would agree with it is not a sequel
because it comes before razor The Lost
Ark the plot holder talking about where
he's never experienced magic before that
kind of thing happens it used to happen
more like to happen in friends a lot
Chandler was like Ross you did music and
then later on in later seasons you find
out that they did music together that's
forgivable in my opinion who gives a
[ __ ] I feel like the fans I have
scrutinized it way harder than anyone
who was involved in the making of it
like they just didn't care the leg is
just another buck it's another fun movie
I feel like people make it a big deal
like calling it like it's actually a
prequel well if you change it to 1937 it
had the exact same script with the exact
same dialogue you'd be like no it's a
sequel that's the only thing that makes
it a prequel is that it says 1935 at the
beginning that's it other than that it's
a sequel you know that's true you're
right I mean if they just changed that
one thing but it wouldn't make it any
better a movie actually there were no
Asian children in 1936
I knew something was historically
inaccurate here's a serious question for
you is spider-man a sequel to Evil Dead
hello reject nation
I'm Greg Alva I'm Chevy Kuwait and I'm
Laura Francesca today we are sitting in
order of most subscribers to Lee
subscribers
Florin can introduce us to the episode
we make cameo in and we'll be together
and then we'll probably do a separate
video on Lauren's channel we'll talk
about our awesome unique experience the
crazy trailer we had set up for us
services of the raft services delivered
food directly to us hopefully you slept
on our couches bagels from Beverly Hills
guys I'm telling you is awesome that's
the setup right there whoa the credits
were I mean honestly the best parts were
meeting him I'm just gonna put that out
there right now really
yeah good if this show goes anywhere
else could we be in a spin-off series
yeah yes we two brothers yeah I get I
get to play myself and you get to play
bad guys anymore yeah cool so guys if
you want a picture of them maybe I'll
like take one of them and make them
autograph it - it's a blatant lie I've
commented on every single video of yours
I haven't received a single I would
never agree to I didn't even sign a
contract to do this video people I got
to give someone an autograph in India
and it was in a Dan Brown book she had
on her at the time I gotta get someone
an autograph and they thought I was my
brother so they tore it up and threw out
hey let the record state that I've got
my hands covered my crotch to avoid this
being a crotch shot I hope they bring
back the kid from the sixth sense
yeah he's got a superpower to see the
show showing up at the end when we bring
in Will Smith Jaden Smith or now
with their no fear thing and then you
bring in a you know that last airbender
you know that was - no no no let's do a
little conjoining on it like you know
Rocket Raccoon but smaller not part of
that and we're gonna subscribe you the
real rejects thanks guys